TESA級別基金的經理費特別的低
我們一般共同基金的經理會每年是收1.5%
但是TESA級別的基金呢
它經理會普遍都收0.6%或0.5%
所以其實就少了大概足足1%
富邦振振新戶優惠來囉
開戶急診500摩比
完成指定任務再領200摩比加500手續費抵用金
還有新宇航空布拉格商務艙雙人機票等你抽
心動不如行動
火速開戶做任務囉
各位觀眾朋友大家好
我是阿雅
你知道TISA是什麼嗎
這個詞聽起來好像很專業
但你只要弄清楚
就可以實際操作咯
今天我們再次邀請
國立臺灣大學財務金融學系
專任教授張森林
來告訴我們TISA制度
對投資人來說有什麼好處
限制又有哪些呢
讓我們歡迎今天的來賓
張教授您好
阿雅好
各位觀眾大家好
教授很多人其實都是
第一次聽到TISA
你能不能用最簡單的方式
來說明TISA到底是什麼呢
TISA它其實就是臺灣個人儲蓄賬戶
它英文叫Taiwan Individual Saving Account
那政府為什麼要推這個制度呢
是因為我們臺灣這個人口老化的
這個問題越來越嚴重
所以政府會擔心說
未來會有越多人退休
然後又擔心他的退休準備不足
所以呢他就是去鼓勵大家
越早開始準備這個退休金越好
我們前面也提到過
其實退休準備應該是越早開始越好
所以政府就是透過這個制度
鼓勵這個投資人呢
儘早去做退休準備的這個投資
那再請教教授
如果從制度設計的邏輯來看
政府會用TESA這樣的新帳戶
主要是想改善投資人什麼樣的問題呢
臺灣人常見的這個投資行為的這個偏誤
就是說他會短線進出
那有時候又太積極會全部all in
所以這個TESA制度的這個設計
就是希望可以去改善投資人
在這方面的這個偏誤
所以呢
你如果申購這個TISA
這個級別的基金的話
政府會有給你一些限制
就是說你要做定期定額
這是第一個
你不能選擇單筆投入
當然就是定期定額
它是可以透過時間
來分散這個風險
好 所以是第一個
它的機制
第二個它要求你
至少要扣滿24個月
因為就是說
不要讓你短線進出
那所以你扣滿24個月
你自然就可以看到
他的績效會慢慢出來
你不能夠說我扣兩三個月我就停
你一定要扣滿24個月
如果沒有扣滿24個月
你在短期內半年內
不能夠再申購同一檔基金
所以他就是透過這個機制來
導正投資人的這個行為的偏誤
那我們想要再延伸問教授就是
TESA制度還有什麼其他的優點呢
好我覺得這個TESA制度
有兩個主要的優點
第一個就是TESA級別基金的
經理費特別的低
我們一般共同基金的經理會
每年是收1.5%
但是TISA級別的基金
它經理會普遍都收0.6%或0.5%
所以其實就少了大概足足1%
它這個經理費
其實跟被動式的指數ETF的經理費
已經非常非常接近
這是它第一個優點
那它的第二個優點
就是它的投資門檻很低
每個月定期定額的金額只要1000塊
所以你可以選擇很多標的
就可以達到這個投資組合分散的這個好處效益
目前多數人的退休金來源主要是老保跟老退
那平均壽命延長以及老保的制度
面臨財務永續壓力的情況下
兩者在未來的現金流可能會有限
想請教授TISA是否能扮演
第三層退休保障的一個角色呢
他一定可以扮演這個第三層退休金的這個角色
因為前面也提到就是
臺灣未來面臨這個少子化跟高齡化的這個趨勢
那所以呢 其實我們的這個
勞保的這個未來的財務的問題
是很嚴重的
所以很有可能說未來如果政府
基於這個財務壓力要去做勞保年金改革
可能勞保年金會被縮水
那當然就會造成民眾
可能退休所得的減少
跟落入貧窮的風險
所以我覺得TISA就是應該要扮演這樣的角色
這個也是政府為什麼積極鼓勵
推出TISA的這個制度的原因
就是希望說
大家先預防性的儲備自己的退休金
萬一說未來政府的財務沒有辦法去負擔
這個勞保年金這麼大的支出的時候
你至少可以靠自己的儲蓄
把這個退休的缺口再把它往上拉
那想再請教教授
對一般投資人來說
投資TISA目前有哪些實際上的條件
規範或是限制
在參與之前有哪些地方
是投資人需要留意的呢
前面有提到就是說
譬如說TISA他要求你要定期定額
至少要扣滿24個月
其實這樣的一個限制是對投資人是好的
因為就很多投資人都是短線進出
其實反而賺不到錢
那可是在國外來講
類似的制度他有更優惠的地方
就是他會在這個租稅上會給你一些誘因
就像我們勞退自體6%不算當年度的所得
所以可以有這個所得稅方面可以有減免
那國外其實他們的退休儲蓄賬戶
也有類似的這種租稅的優惠
那現在政府有在規劃去爭取說
未來這個TESA的這個制度呢
也給這個就是在租稅上的誘因
比如說每年可能給你12萬的額度
你去投資這個TESA基金
然後放在TESA賬戶的話
可以不列入當年度的所得
例如像這樣的租稅誘因
我個人是非常贊成
而且這樣可以讓民眾更有誘因
去做這個TESA的投資
不過如果說未來政府給這個租稅的誘因的話
我覺得要有配套措施
就像勞退自提
你自提到你的個人賬戶之後
其實不能領租
所以如果說TISA級別的基金
你申購以後給你租稅的誘因
然後不列入當年度的所得
那同樣的你也不能隨便把它賣出
一定要等到你退休之後
你才可以去把它賣掉
所以有福利你當然就要給他一些限制
所以這個租稅的誘因
跟對這個賬戶的這個交易的限制
我覺得這個是很合理的
所以應該未來也要做這些規範
那教授最後我們要回到實務面
如果一個投資人理解TISA這個制度
在資產配置或是投資策略上
您建議投資人可以怎麼做調整呢
前面提到TISA基金跟
其實跟一般的這個市場指數ETF
同樣有這個就是經理費的
這個很低的這個費用率很低的這個優點
所以其實是可以考慮
那當然其他國家大部分的研究都發現說
長期投資其實主動式的這個基金不如被動式的ETF
但是這個我們不能只憑印象
我自己有特別去就是把目前
就是我們投信公司推出的這些TISA級別的基金
它的歷史資料拿來做研究
當然它過去只有這個一般級別的基金
那可能有些基金成立歷史也很悠久
我就把他們一般級別的基金的績效
拿來做研究
其實讓我很訝異的是
裡面很多TISA級別的這些基金
其實它過去的歷史績效
是比市場指數的ETF要來得好的
也就是比我們的臺灣加選股價指數ETF的
這個績效要來得好
所以我也就覺得說
可以鼓勵投資人
也可以去不妨考慮看看
因為它有同樣的這個低經理費的這個優點
當然你也要分散
因為過去的績效不代表未來的績效
所以我還會建議投資人
你可以去用過去的資料來挑選
可能3到5檔的這個TESA級別的基金
然後因為它門檻又很低
每個月只要扣1000塊
所以3到5檔一個月扣3000到5000塊
對很多投資人來講都是可行的方案
那這樣的話就可以去比較看看說
譬如說這些TESA級別基金
它未來的績效是不是有機會超過市場指數
我個人認為是有機會
那也可以達到進一步的分散的好處跟效果
所以我會鼓勵投資人去善用這個投資管道
感謝張教授今天精彩的分享
TESA制度就是鼓勵長期投資與為退休做準備
來建立更有機緣的理財習慣
如果你還有想要了解的議題
也歡迎在留言區告訴我們
最後喜歡我們的影片也不要忘記
訂閱按贊開啟小鈴鐺
我們下集再見
拜拜